>> Sean: WELCOME TO HANNITY.
WE BEGIN TONIGHT, THE WALLS ARE
CAVING IN AROUND THE DEEP STATE.
TONIGHT, WE CAN ABSOLUTELY
POSITIVELY REPORT A PIVOTAL
DOCUMENT RELEASE IS ONLY DAYS
AWAY.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TRANSCRIPTS,
SPECIFIC TRANSCRIPTS FROM THE
FBI TOP SURVEILLANCE OF THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN, GEORGE
PAPADOPOULOS AND GEORGE CARTER
AT THE HEIGHT OF THE 2016
ELECTION.
PAPADOPOULOS WILL BE HERE IN A
MOMENT TO PREVIEW THIS MAJOR
DEVELOPMENT.
HE USED EXCULPATORY LANGUAGE AND
WE HAVE THE TAPES AND
TRANSCRIPTS.
AND ACCORDING TO THE SOURCES
THIS IS GROUNDBREAKING
INFORMATION FWILD COPIOUS
AMOUNTS OF EXCULPATORY EVIDENCE.
OBAMA'S D.O.J., COMEY'S FBI HAD
MOUNTAINS OF INFORMATION PROVING
THAT TRUMP-RUSSIA COLLUSION WAS
ALWAYS A HOAX.
THEY KNEW ON IT FIVE DIFFERENT
LEVELS.
MASSIVE RED FLAGS WERE LIMITERED
ALL OVER THE PLACE.
BUT INSTEAD OF PUTTING THE
BREAKS ON THE WITCH HUNT THEY
KEPT DIGGING AND DIGGING AND
DIGGING BLINDED BY RAGE AND
HATRED, DESPERATE TO TAKE DOWN
THE PRESIDENT, DONALD TRUMP,
THEY NEVER UNDERSTOOD WHY HE
WON.
THEY DIDN'T THINK OF IT.
BY THE WAY, THEIR GUIDING LIGHT
THE ENTIRE TIME, HILLARY
CLINTON'S RUSSIAN BOUGHT AND
PAID FOR UNVERIFIABLE DIRTY
DOSSIER FULL OF LIES.
A CLEAR EXAMPLE OF WHAT IS
PREMEDITATED FRAUD, CONSPIRACY,
AGAINST TRUMP, MEMBERS OF HIS
CAMPAIGN, AND GUESS WHAT, ON
FISA COURTS.
ALL MUST BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
THANKFULLY, TRUTH DID PREVAIL,
FOUR SEPARATE INVESTIGATIONS TO
DATE HAVE CLEARED THE PRESIDENT
AND HIS CAMPAIGN OF ANY AND ALL
WRONG DOING.
THE HOAX HAS BEEN LAID BARE FOR
ALL TO SEE.
WE WILL GIVE YOU SO MUCH MORE
INFORMATION.
DEMOCRATS IN CONGRESS,
APPARENTLY THEY HAVEN'T GOTTEN
THE MEMO.
JERRY NADLER'S CLOWN SHOW IS IN
FULL SWING, NEVER ENDING STRING
OF FRIVOLOUS SUBPOENAS, AFTER
FAILING TO HAUL IN DON McGANN.
NADLER ISSUED SUBPOENAS FOR HIS
CHIEF OF STAFF.
EVEN FORMER AID HOPE HICKS,
CURRENTLY SERVES AS EBP AT THIS
NETWORK, HERE AT FOX.
WE'RE GOING TO MAKE HOPE HICKS
SPEND ANOTHER MILLION DOLLARS ON
LAWYERS TO ANSWER THE SAME EXACT
QUESTIONS AGAIN?
ONLY THIS TIME IT WILL BE A
PERJURY TRAP, GOD FORBID ANYONE
THAT GOES BEFORE CONGRESS, THEY
HAVE ONE MINOR DETAIL, ONE
LITTLE DISCREPANCY.
THAT'S WRONG OR DIFFERENT FROM
THE LAST TIME THEY TESTIFIED.
IT'S CALLED A PERJURY TRAP.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL, BARR,
DEFIED A REQUEST TO APPEAR
BEFORE NADLER'S CIRCUS.
HE'S NOW SPEAKING OUT TELLING
THE "WALL STREET JOURNAL,"
QUOTE, I FELT THE RULES WERE
BEING CHANGED TO HURT THE
PRESIDENT, PRESIDENT TRUMP, AND
I THOUGHT IT WAS DAMAGING TO THE
PRESIDENCY OVER THE LONG HAUL.
IF YOU DESTROY THE PRESIDENCY,
AND MAKE IT AN ERRAND BOY FOR
CONGRESS, WE'RE GOING TO BE A
MUCH WEAKER, MORE DIVIDED
NATION.
DEMOCRATS DON'T SEEM TO CARE.
THEY'RE STILL FUMING.
AND DON'T FORGET, CLINTON AID
BRIAN PAGLIANO, HILLARY'S AID,
SERVER, HE TOTALLY IGNORED HIS
2016 CONGRESSIONAL SUBPOENA
RELATED TO THE HILLARY E-MAIL
SCANDAL INVESTIGATION.
AT THE TIME DEMOCRATS, THEY
COULD HAVE CARED LESS.
AGAIN, SELECTIVE MORAL OUTRAGE.
WE ARE NOW WITNESSING THIS
SELECTIVE OUTRAGE AT ITS WORST.
MEANWHILE, JERRY NADLER'S SIR
KULGS IS EAGER TO FEATURE, THEY
WANT ROBERT MUELLER TO COME N
DEMOCRATS HOPE FOR ONE LAST
GROUND OF BASELESS TRUMP
CONSPIRACY THEORIES AND HOAXES
THEY CAN PERPETRATE ON THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
TEAM MUELLER IS REPORTEDLY
RELUCTANT TO TESTIFY PUBLICLY,
PLOIB FOR GOOD REASON.
WE WILL HAVE TO ANSWER IN HIS
CASE VERY IMPORTANT QUESTIONS
FOR EXAMPLE, I'D LIKE TO KNOW
WHY DID MUELLER HIRE A TEAM OF
ONLY DEMOCRATIC DONORS?
WHY DID HE HIRE HILLARY
CLINTON'S FORMER ATTORNEY FOR
THE CLINTON FOUNDATION?
WHY WOULD HE EVER GIVE SO MUCH
POWER TO ANDREW WEISSMANN, HYPER
PARTISAN, HILLARY-LOVING HACK,
AT HILLARY'S VICTORY PARTY WITH
AN ATROCIOUS PROTECTIONAL TRACK
RECORD.
WHEN DID HE REALIZE RUSSIA
COLLUSION NEVER HAPPENED?
WHEN DID HE LEARN ABOUT
HILLARY'S BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
RUSSIAN DOSSIER.
AND BY THE WAY, TO IMPACT THE
RACE, THAT'S IMPORTANT.
MUELLER NEEDS ON ANSWER, IF HE
HAD TIME TO INVESTIGATE TAXI
MEDALLIONS, DECADES OLD TAX
RETURNS, BANK FRAUD ON LOAN
APPLICATIONS, PERJURY, HE DIDN'T
HAVE TIME ON LOOK INTO REAL
EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION?
BECAUSE IT FEATURED HILLARY, THE
HEART OF HIS SO-CALLED MANDATE?
AND CHRISTOPHER STEELE, MULTIPLE
FOREIGN GOVERNMENTS NO, TIME FOR
THAT EITHER.
BY THE WAY, I HAVE BAD NEWS FOR
THE DEMOCRATS, LOOK AT THIS
POLL, MOST AMERICANS, THEY ARE
NOT INTERESTED IN MUELLER
APPEARING BEFORE CONGRESS.
THEY GOT IT.
THEY READ IT.
IT'S OVER.
YOU JUST DON'T RECOGNIZE A
SIMPLE TRUTH.
THE MITCH HUNT IS DONE.
THE ONLY THING -- THE WITCH HUNT
IS DONE.
THE SECOND ACT THAT, CURTAIN
GOES UP, BUT YOU HAVE IT RAD CAM
BASE OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
CALLING FOR IMPEACHMENT LONG
INTO TRUMP'S SECOND TERM.
NANCY PELOSI, ONLY SPEAKER OF
THE HOUSE IN NAME ONLY, BEING
PUSHED AROUND BY HER COLLEAGUES,
FRESHMAN CONGRESSWOMAN SOCIALIST
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ IS THE
REAL SPEAKER, DEMANDING THE
PRESIDENT BE REMOVED FROM
OFFICE.
AND NANCY BETTER WATCH OUT AND
LISTEN.
>> ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ I
CALL UP WITH, ALSO SAID THIS
CAUCUS SHOULD NOT BE HESITANT IN
MOVING FORWARD WITH IMPEACHMENT.
>> YOU KNOW, I INSTRUCTED -- I'M
NOT SURE SAYING EVERYONE.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
>> Sean: NANCY PELOSI, SPEAKER
IN NAME ONLY, LOST ALL CONTROL
IN THE U.S. HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES.
BY THE WAY, SAD SIGHT TO REALLY
BEHOLD.
SHE'S UTTERLY POWERLESS TO THE
RADICAL DEMANDS FROM
OCASIO-CORTEZ AND OTHERS, AND
ACCORDING TO A REPORT FROM PLIPT
I CO-MASSIVE INFIGHTING AMONG
CAPITOL HILL DEMOCRATS AND
THEIBLE FIGHTING IN FULL GEAR IN
THE DEEP STATES.
CONGRESSMAN DOUG COLLINS ISSUED
MASSIVE DOCUMENT RELEASE,
HUNDREDS OF PAGES, CLOSED DOOR
TESTIMONY TRANSCRIPTS, LORETTA
LYNCH, McCABE.
WE KNOW THAT LORETTA LYNCH WAS
PRETTY MUCH ACCUSING JAMES COMEY
OF LYING BEFORE CONGRESS.
THAT WOULD BE LYING BEFORE
CONGRESS, TESTIFYING UNDER OATH,
THAT SHE NEVER ASKED COMEY TO
REFER TO THE CLINTON CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION AS JUST A MATTER
THE WAY COMEY SAID.
SOMEBODY IS LYING, SOMEBODY
COMMITTED PERJURY.
THE ONLY QUESTION NOW IS WAS IT
COMEY OR WAS IT LYNCH OR MAYBE
BOTH?
AND COMING UP WE HAVE TREASURE
TROVE OF DEVELOPMENTS FROM THESE
NEWLY RELEASED TRANSCRIPTS, IT'S
PRETTY CLEAR THE HIGH-RANKING
ANTI-TRUMP OFFICIALS IN THE DEEP
STATE ARE SCARED AND FORMING A
CIRCULAR FIRING SQUAD AS THE
WALLS BEGIN TO CAVE IN.
THEY KNOW WHAT THEY DID, THEY
KNOW THEY'RE IN DEEP TROUBLE,
AND BREAKING TONIGHT JOHN
SOLOMON IS BACK WITH ANOTHER
BOMBSHELL NEW REPORT.
DETAILING YET ANOTHER RED FLAG
IN THE FBI WITCH HUNT INTO THE
TRUMP-RUSSIA SO-CALLED
COLLUSION.
ACCORDING TO JOHN SOLOMON,
INVESTIGATIVE REPORTER FOR "THE
HILL" STATE DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL
KATHLEEN KAVALEK DID SEND THE
FBI A SALACIOUS PIECE OF
SO-CALLED INTELLIGENCE FROM HER
MEETING WHEN CH WAS NOT
APPROPRIATE WITH CHRISTOPHER
STEELE.
ONLY PROBLEM THE INTEL WAS TOTAL
AND COMPLETE B.S. WHICH COULD
HAVE EASILY BEEN DISPROVEN WITH
ANY SIMPLE LEVEL OF
VERIFICATION.
IT NEVER HAPPENED.
SEVERAL DAYS LATER COMEY USED
STEELE'S B.S. AS THE BASIS FOR
THE FISA REQUEST AND HE SIGNED